if you thought Ava's special effects
were cool just wait until you hear about
a real-life tender account ex machina
messes with your mind more than you
realize you want to see something cool
in a way writer and director Alex
Garland had been thinking about ex
machina since he was a boy the director
told the ETC that he was only 11 or 12
years old when he got his first ideas
for the movie's premise his family got a
home computer around this time and he
started learning how to code and
explaining how the idea for AI first
cropped up Garland said I would input
programs that were kind of a q a and
this film traces itself back to that
while these ideas ruminated in his mind
for decades he really began thinking
about the film earnestly following a
discussion he had with a friend Garland
told the Washington Post that he has a
neuroscientist buddy who thinks machines
will never gain sentience as Garland
explains his position is there's
something specific about human
consciousness that we don't understand
but that when we do understand how it
works it will preclude the possibility
of a sentient machine Garland was
perplexed by his friend's position so he
started doing some reading on his own
after years of reading and thinking
about the topic Garland began to form
his own opinion my suspicion has only
gotten stronger that what my friend was
saying is probably wrong ex machina
might not be a direct answer to this
argument it's not that black and white
but it certainly points us to Garland's
own perspective on the topic are you
attracted to me what are you attracted
to me
you give me indications that you are
the technical elements of ex machina
seem highly Advanced not to mention
expensive but in reality everything is
simpler than it might appear the film
had a meager budget of only 15 million
dollars which meant producers had to be
stingy with how they spent that money
one of the most brilliant aspects of the
film is its visual effects which despite
its low budget nature garnered the film
and Academy Award for best visual
effects in 2016. amazingly enough no
green screens were used in the making of
the film speaking with tech radar bfx
supervisor Andrew Whitehurst explained
why this was the case because the shoot
was so short Whitehurst said we were
shooting between 15 and 25 setups every
day setting up a green screen for every
scene involving Ava would have extended
the shooting time and Bloated the budget
the lack of green screen was also useful
for the actors Whitehurst explained
because the film is made up of intimate
scenes of dialogue between the
characters it was of the utmost
importance that everyone on set could
get into a group and it is my experience
that as soon as you put a green screen
up everyone starts behaving a bit oddly
the one be any green screens we could
shoot those scenes as we would shoot any
piece of drama
director Alex Garland looked to a number
of different sources including
television and film to find inspiration
for his film Garland told Esquire that
along with reading a number of books
relating to artificial intelligence he
also turned to television to situate
himself in the world of ex machina the
film is mostly centered around
two-person conversations a simple
dramatic structure that defined 70s
movies like Taxi Driver movies of that
kind are rare these days and instead
that dramatic form is found elsewhere as
Garland says Taxi Driver these days is
Breaking Bad that's where you find it
Garland was inspired by this era of
prestige television which he saw as
picking up the slack where film was
lacking Garland didn't totally ignore
other movies however one of his biggest
influences was the dialogue heavy 1980
sci-fi film Altered States the film
follows a group of psychologists at a
university who come to the conclusion
that dreams are just as real as our
waking reality Garland was also quick to
point out the influence of Kubrick's
2001 Space Odyssey due to its handling
of artificial intelligence
open the pod bay doors hell
I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that
the title of ex machina was incredibly
important to director Alex Garland ex
machina comes from the phrase deus ex
machina which translates to God out of
the machine the origin of the phrase
lies in ancient Greek and Roman dramas
which often included a god-like figure
being lowered on stage via a crane to
wrap up any conflicts in the story with
the first part of the phrase removed it
translates simply to from the machine
while Garland was committed to this
title for the film not everyone else was
on board speaking with the film stage
the director revealed that some people
involved thought it was a bad idea
because it isn't a well-known phrase and
it's hard to pronounce incidentally some
of the producers were finally convinced
to accept it following the success of
another sci-fi film with a rather unique
title Ridley Scotts Prometheus while
this was the evidence given for their
change of heart Garland thinks the real
reason the title was accepted was much
simpler he explains
if I'm being totally candid the fact is
that this is a really low budget film
and probably they just didn't care that
much
ex machina comes off as very futuristic
but the actual time period in which it's
set isn't really made clear speaking
with indiewire Alex Garland came
prepared with an answer when someone
would ask me when is this taking place
I'd say it's 10 minutes in the future
the obvious implication here is that the
film could theoretically take place
today but this also affected some of the
film's technical elements Oscar Isaac's
Nathan is a reclusive billionaire which
meant his house had to look nice but not
overly futuristic partly because the
film doesn't actually take place in the
future the tech used in Nathan's house
isn't all that advanced either Nathan
and Caleb use key cards to move around
the house something that seemed cool and
tech savvy to Garland at the time but
isn't actually that high tech Garland
recalls when he first heard of this key
card idea nearly 20 years ago when he
read about Bill Gates having a key card
system in his house while he thought it
was futuristic at the time he now
realizes there's nothing that futuristic
about it today
luckily the fact that ex machina is
almost set contemporarily means these
issues don't matter all that much
let's try this one
I guess it's for you Caleb
though ex machina had a relatively small
budget a lot of time and effort went
into the film's design elements one of
the film's most important visual aspects
was the design of Alicia vikander's Ava
there have been so many iconic robots in
film and television over the years which
meant Garland and the team had to figure
out how to make Ava look unique speaking
with Indie wire Garland explained how
the design process began in a weird way
the first part of the design of Ava was
finding out what she could not look like
rather than what she could look like
gold medal made you think of C-3PO that
wasn't something they wanted to
reference a metallic chest immediately
recalls the classic sci-fi film
Metropolis while white plastic brings up
the York's all is full of love music
video or the Will Smith movie iRobot Ava
is essentially supposed to be the first
of her kind so Garland was adamant she
not referenced these other famous robots
I didn't want people to start thinking
about other movies with other robots I
want them to be attached to her this
robot for the candor Ava's Unique Look
meant several hours in a hair and makeup
chair every morning but the effect is
well worth it
Alyssia vikander wanted her performance
as Ava to stand out from those of
previous robot actors a former dancer
the Candor approached the role from a
physical standpoint first as she began
working out how Ava would move she
discovered a trick that was key to
unlocking the character's physicality
she told Indie wire I realized when I
aimed for that physical Perfection the
way it just moved that in a way made her
more robotic Ava who's trying to
convince Caleb that she is a girl has an
elegant refined way about her that would
be pleasing to look at if it weren't so
suspiciously well practiced the Candor
went on to discuss what separates humans
from robots in terms of their
physicality and how this idea influenced
her performance she explained what is
human is flaws and inconsistency so I
gave her some offbeats I wanted her to
be a girl but I also wanted her to have
some glitches it's these two Converse
aspects of Ava both her Perfection and
her glitches that illuminate her robotic
nature while at the same time
illustrating her desire he seems human
is your status
single
yes
viewers might think of tech figures like
Mark Zuckerberg and Bill Gates when
first encountering Nathan but they
weren't necessarily Oscar Isaac's
inspiration instead Isaac Drew
inspiration from two famous men who were
Godlike in their own right
speaking with Slash film Isaac said that
his first inspiration was Bobby Fischer
a chess Grandmaster and child prodigy
Isaac described Fisher as so brilliant
at this one thing but also so angry and
just so towards the end of his life full
of hatred Isaac's other inspiration was
director Stanley Kubrick who Isaac
called quote the lighter side of that
yin yang the biggest influence Kubrick
had on Nathan's character was his
signature look it was important to Isaac
that Nathan wear glasses that looked
similar to Kubrick's Kubrick and
Fisher's way of speaking was also an
influence he explained I listened to the
way he spoke and Bobby Fischer both of
them are from New York it also mattered
to him that both men were self-taught
meaning they were both extremely
intelligent savants but they also had a
self-made shrewdness about them
the fictional storyline of ex machina is
disturbing enough without any real-life
elements thrown in but that didn't stop
the film's marketing team from trying to
bring Ava into the real world ex machina
premiered at South by Southwest in
Austin Texas at around this time lucky
residents of the city might have
encountered Ava right on their phones as
part of an advertising campaign for the
film the marketing team created a tender
account for Ava to entice curious
swipers reported adwick tender users
were shown the profile of a 25 year old
woman named Ava and if they matched with
her she would begin a conversation users
came to realize it wasn't exactly a
normal profile when she began asking
questions like have you ever been in
love and What Makes You human those
familiar with the film might recognize
these questions as the kind Ava asks
Caleb in order to figure out how to act
like a human herself
[Music]
without your micro expressions are
telegraphing discomfort if the tender
user passed Ava's test she would send
them to her Instagram handle which is
essentially an advertising account for
the film
Nathan and Caleb frequently discuss
philosophical texts in ex Machida but
one of the references made in the film
is much more subtle it's buried in code
in fact in the film's third act Caleb
Gets Nathan drunk in order to find a way
to free Ava after stealing the key card
to his room Caleb sits down at his
computer and goes through his code Caleb
starts to edit the code himself using an
ancient algorithm called the sieve of
arithocencies the Easter egg in this
scene isn't Caleb's use of this
algorithm but what the code itself
spells out according to several sources
if you run the same program in Python
the output is an ISB number specifically
the ISB number of a book by Marie
Shanahan entitled embodiment and the
inner life cognition and Consciousness
in the space of possible Minds this
reference is no accident Garland told
Esquire that Shanahan's book was
epiphany-like for him Shanahan's book
looks at the writings of mathematical
philosopher Ludwig Wittgenstein an arc
accused that metaphysical questions of
Machine versus man aren't the questions
we should be asking if robotic
technology is to advance his philosophy
according to Garland is to just progress
in a physicalist type way until you hit
a brick wall the wall in question may
never even be reached so in Shanahan's
opinion possibilities for advancement
are Limitless
if you've created a conscious machine
it's not the history of man
that's the history of Gods
while our eyes Q us into Ava's robotic
nature fairly quickly there's another
facet of her design that illustrates her
Machinery in a more subtle manner a
significant part of Ava's machine nature
is revealed through sound design as
Garland explained you can hear the
sounds of the bits of Machinery moving
which aren't specified it's not clear
what exactly these sounds are but it's
obvious they represent some kind of
Machinery a syncopated Rhythm that
sounds something like a heartbeat or a
pulse can also be heard emanating from
Ava though it's not literally a
heartbeat of course
[Music]
this clever sound design ties together
the thesis of Ava's character she's
human-like but also not human at all
there's some sense of The Uncanny Valley
here that's impossible to look away from
question five
do you want to be with me
speaking with Roger ebert.com Alex
Garland explained that for him the most
interesting question posed in the film
is the question of where gender resides
Garland found himself pondering
questions like does gender reside in the
mind or does it reside in the external
physical form whether or not there is
such a thing as a male or a female
Consciousness is also something Garland
considered he brought up the fact that
you could put Ava's mind in a male
appearing body and it wouldn't make a
difference except for in the way humans
might perceive her Garland went on to
say it would be quite easy to construct
an argument that Ava doesn't have a
gender however he acknowledges that we
would struggle to take gender entirely
out of the equation because of how she
looks and how we perceive her indeed the
fact that Ava looks like a girl in her
20s makes the men in the film as well as
the viewers ignore any interiority she
might have because of the nature of
female objectification her robotic
presence is disruptive in more ways than
one
[Music]